vice president kamala harris speaking
out about the influx of migrants at the
border
and saying she will travel down to
mexico and guatemala to address root
causes
of the issue take a look the
president has asked secretary
mayorkis to address what is going on at
the border
i have been asked to lead the issue of
dealing with root causes in the northern
triangles
i have talked with the president of
mexico the
president of guatemala we have well i'm
probably saying too much but we have
plans in the work to go guatemala
as soon as possible
and house republicans criticizing the
vice president for not visiting the
southern border
by putting her face on a milk carton
judge let me ask you this she's she
she's starting off the vice president
not visiting a southern town
is it right uh to visit mexico and
guatemala first as we think about a
immigration policy that that's not
working
well you know for me and i've been to
the border uh
several times uh i think that since it
impacts the united states i would
i would suggest that the first place you
go
is the southern border whether it's in
texas or whether it's in arizona
to assess how the influx or the surge
which aoc says is a racist term
how the surge is impacting small towns
in the united states
the fact that they're not testing the
kids for coven to see what actually is
the truth
to see what the media wants to see what
the biden administration won't let them
see
this is america we're interested in
protecting americans
she can find out what the root causes
are and i think obviously i think it's
hysterical she's doing it as soon as
possible
she got the assignment three weeks ago
how long does it take to get to
guatemala
and mexico you know i i i don't mean to
be a skeptic herald
but i got to tell you the pain is being
felt
at the southern border if you want to
know what the problem is
it's all about money and poverty and
gangs in those countries
but they're bringing it right here we
don't know who's coming in we don't know
what their records are
who they are if they have a record at
all it's it's
we got 10 million americans out of work
because of the pandemic
and we're opening up the border and you
can't say it's closed because i've been
there it's not closed
but i hope that answers your question
kind of in a nice way
jesse judge i appreciate that when you
think about the root causes and you talk
about the gangs and the violence and i
would even argue that
the awful weather uh patterns over the
last several years that have ravaged
those communities
is not addressing the root causes of
this really the way to prevent
or to lower those numbers of record
numbers of children and families coming
to the border
the root causes aren't in the northern
triangle they're in the west wing harold
i would go there instead that's it's
biden's rhetoric and policies that
triggered this record smashing surge
this is why joe biden took such a long
time to pick a vp
to begin with he initially wanted susan
rice because he trusted her
but then was told that he had to take
kamala harris
even though he didn't know if she was
loyal because remember he called
him a racist at the debate but he was
convinced and now she's starting to show
signs of disloyalty when a president of
the united states taps the vp
to take charge of something that means
it's an important job
that means it's very important but it's
also dirty and the president doesn't
want to get his hands dirty so as a
loyal vp
you have to just dive right in headfirst
and do your job
and she didn't she treated the border
like a hot potato she's like no no no
it's not me
you do it you do it dhs i don't want
this i'm only going to do diplomacy
so she's going to fly down to guatemala
and and she's going to sit across from a
corrupt politician and said i'm going to
send you a bunch of money
and they're going to smile and nod their
head and say yeah i'll do something and
then they'll wink to their buddy and the
money will end up in their bank account
and then the surge will probably die
down in the summer when it's too hot to
migrate and she'll pat herself on the
shoulder and said she fixed it
but it's just gonna start right back up
again and break another record in the
winter dana one of the last presidents
to think seriously about
immigration reform and make an effort
was was your former boss uh president
bush
i've listened and i don't necessarily
agree disagree totally with what's being
said but
at the same time do we not think about
this
differently than it's a great political
point for either side we invest billions
in the middle east to stabilize that
region
yet we've invested very little in our
own hemisphere is that something that
the vice president should be thinking
about and weighing as she tries to come
up with an answer
that's a very good question i do want to
just defend president obama who i think
will be so offended to think he hadn't
taken it seriously i kid harold i can't
um
i think that every president since
george washington has had some sort of
immigration issue to deal with
and this one i think one solving the
problem at its source i think would be
great
i definitely think that our southern
hemisphere has been ignored for a long
time
and actually it was very interesting to
talking to general peter pace you might
remember
him from as he was the first marine to
be joint chiefs of staff i remember
asking him where he was on 9 11.
you know where he was he had just landed
in colombia because
that was going to be a big focus get the
the drug
cartels uh underway but then what
happened
9 11. and we led this we just had a
segment about afghanistan over 20 years
so yeah i think there's a lot here
i do think with kamala harris it's very
interesting most vice presidents
do anything to try to find some sort of
substantive issue
that they can hold on to so that they
could actually be
in the news but this time it's like whoa
whoa whoa like
backing up and she she doesn't
necessarily want to take it all on i
would love to see her take it all on i
think that would be
actually probably very good for her
political career and
maybe even good for the country because
she could get the visibility that it
needs secretary mallorcas has been to
the border i think four times and nobody
knows about it
the last thing i'd say is the washington
post did this puff piece on her
um it was this feature story about how
she's crocheting
and how amazing it is like i i just
it makes me think that george bush
should have put dick cheney in charge of
like a knitting circle
instead of the energy task force that
might have
that might have given us some better
press
greg i know you have a lot of thoughts
on this i do first off
harold stop asking good questions it's
bad enough that i'm no longer the best
looking person on the five
just stop trying to add substance to
this debate it's making me sick to my
stomach
all right this crocheting thing is
amazing so this is how the media is
looking at her during this crisis
let's do a feature on crocheting by the
way i love to crochet
but you know what it does explain why
she's always laughing
because she's constantly in stitches
awesome dana dana i'm going to end on a
corny joke what did joe biden
say to kamala harris when he found her
in a closet
doing her crochet what did he say
i'm beginning to see a
[Laughter]
oh pattern good very yes
sorry harold i didn't answer your
questions